this is Matt BMA and this is Jonathan
Bailey and we're here with BuzzFeed to
answer some questions whilst playing
with puppies I'm really excited yeah I
feel good this is the the easiest press
has ever been
[Music]
know oh oh my
goodness oh done bye hi
baby give Johny some love guys all I'll
just wait patiently guys and GS come on
this one's a little
adventurous he's got his
raccoon we had not met but I was a huge
fan of of Jonathan's work as an actor
and as a puppy Wrangler and as a puppy
Wrangler especially yeah and then we met
at at coffee and I I I knew I had an
amazing scene partner that I could trust
I wish I could bring you home this was
so calm yeah oh oh
wow dramatically the 50s were incredible
yeah and for all the reasons of the
Nuance of all the different characters
and then mixing that up with the' 70s oh
oh hey hey he got the
point what's our love language this like
oh sorry baby sorry baby well we could
talk about our characters I think Tims
is words ofation oh yeah yeah un touch I
yeah Haws is definitely touch and
gifts
the strangest one were my friends in my
church group in high school called me
boat meal I don't know where it came
from that's the strangest I don't know
it's certainly not my favorite oatmeal I
think it was a combination of bower and
oatmeal cuz at some church Retreat I had
oatmeal in the morning that's a sensible
way to start the day yeah slow
releasing um yeah load everybody calls
your nicknames JB JB yeah yeah Jo is is
my my family family
[Music]
nickname oh hey hey you are so aggro
dude it's all right it's all right look
we get it you're the alpha much like for
so many people because the strike is
lifted everyone seemed to be doing
interviews everywhere but all at the
same hotels and downstairs was Andrew
and Paul and uh we just got sort of
ushered down that like a a corridor and
then they were like it it's like a
full-blown Gladiator match my absolute
favorite is the uh the comment that went
with the picture that was this is what
it would be like if the hobbits at the
sh I got
Zara that comment brought my
[Music]
world every other you crushed it every
day like I don't think you ever even
struggle it well there's something you
know the the the filming hours are crazy
yeah in North America so you can do you
know you can film up to sort of 18 hours
a day this project especially we had we
had some late nights and I think I just
kept looking every day I was like is
this can't we
go as a result of that accent wise you
either it either works in your favor or
it doesn't depend on the moment when I'm
tired or if I've been working 14 hours
like my Southern accent can start to
come back so I have to be conscious of
that too what what do they say like
drunk drunk tired or angry hey hey hey
hey take it easy
pal
[Music]
roller coasters oh really like the
physics of it or I was obsessed with
roller coasters as a teenag what's your
favorite roller coaster X2 is X Flags if
we're going back to Childhood I was
really obsessed with
turtles really obsessed with turtles I
got to see some of the eggs hatching and
was really like fascinated by sea
turtles I feel like you've both got
you've got a similar Grace I think you
and Turtles the way they move your
you've got that Elegance I think thank
you
Jonathan
Bailey without question my or
um nice
[Music]
nice hey honestly kind of lame but
probably just like a little extra
caffeine nothing crazy oh oh also the
lasagna at EOD in New York City I think
it's like a 12 layer lasagna I always
think about you and London Fog cookies
oh yes Johnny brought some London Fog
cookies that were fire the
[Music]
set I auditioned for I bet you did as
well um when Taran was on stage oh my
God the Tarzan
Musical and there was a there was a
gorilla callback if you got through the
singing portion of it you had to come
back and just behave as a gorilla
and then transition from a gorilla to a
human and then like sing the song and
act as a gorilla and a human well Barbie
I was I plan on doing Barbie and then I
got Maestro so I couldn't do that
because it was too much time away from
my family but I love gret I would have
loved to have done that I dressed up as
like five different Kens I had like a
Malibu Ken look I had like a classic Ken
look I really went for
[Music]
it I'd been aware of the phenomenon of
sort of mcarthism and how gay people
were so oppressed to it and then I just
think it was such an incredible
experience to go and explore 30 years
but four Decades of of the queer
experience in America yeah how
extraordinary it is that that story has
never been told never been told yeah not
on not on the screen I knew about the
lavender scare but I really didn't know
the specifics of it that this executive
order had been passed um by Eisenhower
because of McCarthy and uh Roy con oh oh
take it easy on your on your brother
private parts there
[Music]
pal oh my gosh Bradley is like I I
honestly hope that every actor gets to
work with him at some point because
they're all fighting for the next Brad
movie um okay you got the rooll you got
the
[Music]
rooll I do yeah yeah I do very much she
wrangled quite a um hello magical group
of people and yeah she's Mega and also
everyone who's worked with Phoebe is
connected via theater from years ago
thank you so much BuzzFeed for having us
please tune in to fellow Travelers on
Showtime I'm Paramount
plus all of these puppies are adaptable
from muddy
[Music]
pools
he